THIS IS THE TRUE STORY OF SIX (BEEP) STRANGERS
BEIN' PUT IN
A (BLEEP) HOUSE...
AND HAVIN' THEIR (BLEEP)'
LIVES TAPED...
FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
PEOPLE STOP BEIN' ALL POLITE
AND (BLEEP) AND START
BEIN' REAL.
MAD REAL.
MAD REAL WORLD,
SON.
( all )
HOBOKEN !
A'IGHT ?
ALL RIGHT ?
WHEN I FIRST ENTERED THE HOUSE,
UM, YOU KNOW...
NEEDLESS TO SAY,
I WAS A LITTLE SURPRISED
TO MEET THE OTHER ROOMMATES.
SORRY, SORRY.
HOW YA DOIN' ?
WHAT'S UP, BABY ?
( all arguing )
( woman )
WHAT ? WHAT ?
HEY, WHAT'S GOIN' ON ?
MY NAME IS CHAD.
( coughing )
( muttering )
I DON'T HANG OUT
WITH MANY BLACK PEOPLE.
WHO ORDERED PIZZA ?
NO, NO, NO, I, I--
I'M YOUR NEW ROOMMATE, RIGHT ?
YOU WANNA-- YOU WANNA ROOM ?
NAH, UH,
ALL THE BEDS IS FULL.
YOU GOT TO ROOM
WITH TYREE.
( Tyree )
MY NAME IS TYREE,
AND, YEAH,
I WENT TO PRISON.
I'M-- I'M YOUR
ROOMMATE, CHAD.
WELL, LOOKY HERE, CHAD,
FOR THE ENTIRE PERIOD
YOU IN MY ROOM,
I BETTER NOT CATCH
YOU STANDIN' UP PEEIN'.
YOU SIT DOWN WHEN YOU PEE,
YOU UNDERSTAND ?
UH...
THAT'S RIGHT.
NOW, GET YOUR FAT ASS ON
OUT OF HERE, WHITE BOY.
NIGHTY-NIGHT,
KEEP YOUR BUTTHOLE TIGHT.
LET ME TRY ON SOME
COTTON DOCKERS, HA-HA-HA.
WHAT'S THE SQUARE ROOT
OF THIS APARTMENT ?
HE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT HE WAS
GETTING HIMSELF INTO, YOU KNOW ?
♪ WE PERSEVERE ♪
THEY GAVE US A JOB
RUNNING THE JUICE BAR.
ALL RIGHT, ENJOY.
THANKS A LOT.
I WASN'T REALLY CRAZY
ABOUT THE WAY
SOME OF THE OTHER ROOMMATES, UM,
ACTED IN THE JUICE BAR.
( coughing )
LOOK AT ME, AMERICA,
I'M MAKIN' JUICE.
I CALL THIS,
"THE TRON SPECIAL."
BOO-YA !
THIS RIGHT HERE IS
THE GOOD (BLEEP).
DRIP, DRIP, DRIP, DRIP...
IT'S JUST BETTER IF, UH...
GET OUTTA MY FACE,
NIGGA !
I'M MAKING
JUICE, ALL RIGHT ?
FINE, FINE, YOU MAKE YOUR JUICE,
I DON'T KNOW.
WHOA !
THEY DIDN'T HAVE MUCH RESPECT
FOR THE JOB.
( Tron )
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
HOLD ON, LET ME ROLL,
ONE MORE ROLL, ONE MORE ROLL.
HEY, UH, GUYS,
YOU KNOW, UH--
WE'RE HERE
TO WORK, NOT PLAY.
YOU KNOW, WE CAN'T HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION EVERY DAY.
HEY !
YO, WHAT IS YOUR PROBLEM,
MAN ?!
WHY YOU WANNA
WORK SO HARD, HUH ?!
YEAH, MAN, AMERICA WANNA SEE US
LIVE, NOT WORK.
LOOK AT ME, AMERICA,
LOOK HOW TRON IS LIVING.
FOR THE CITY...
GET YOUR ASS
OUTTA HERE, NOW !
THIS IS A PLACE
OF BUSINESS...
WELL, BRING SOME
JUICE BACK!
SELL ME SOME JUICE, BITCH,
I'M THIRSTY !
GET ME
A PHILLY BLUNT, SON.
AND A BANANA
COGNAC, BIATCH !
C'MON, A-CLICKETY-CLACK,
A-CLICKETY-CLACK.
( sirens wailing )
POLICE, POLICE,
THEY COMIN' THIS WAY !
THIS WAY, COME ON,
Y'ALL !
GET MY MONEY !
HURRY, GET MY MONEY !